[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN GORNER: So
who in the audience
would describe themselves
as developers or computer
engineers with a new skill
set in machine learning?
Quite a few.
So that's a good thing.
And I would like to share
with you a couple of tools
that you can use day to
day to work faster and more
efficiently.
TPUs is, of course,
one of them, but there
will be a couple of others.
So this is a TPU v2.
This is a TPU v3.
Those are fairly large boards.
It's like this, roughly.
And each one of those
boards has four chips.
Each chip is a dual core chip.
And those accelerators
are designed specifically
to accelerate machine
learning workloads.
You can get them as
boards like this.
You can also get
them as a full rack.
It's called a pod.
And the trick is that
in a rack, all the TPUs
are interconnected on a high
performance interconnect which
makes them look like a single
accelerator to your workload.
So you don't have to handle
complicated distribution code.
The only thing you do is
you increase your batch size
to work on those
bigger machines.
And just a couple of words
of what makes them special.
Inside of a TPU--
so a board, four
chips, eight cores--
in each one of those
cores, you have two things.
One is a fairly traditional
vector processing unit--
so that's a vector processor--
and the second one,
that is what makes this
special for machine learning,
is a matrix multiply unit.
So it's a specific unit--
hardware unit-- that is
dedicated to performing 128
by 128 matrix multiplications
in reduced precision in a format
called bfloat 16.
And machine learning
workloads are
full of matrix multiplications.
So by having this dedicated
hardware in there,
this is what accelerates
machine learning workload,
specifically.
Now, about this precision,
so using reduced precision
is a fairly common trick
in machine learning.
Usually, you do so in float16,
the standard float16 precision.
But as you see here, float16
has only five exponent bits,
so fewer than
float32, which means
that when you reduce
the precision,
sometimes you get under
flows or overflows
and you have to do
additional work on your model
to overcome that.
It's not necessarily
complicated, but it's work.
And so what we did
in TPUs is that we
used a slightly different
16-bit format called bfloat16,
and you see it has exactly the
same number of exponent bits
than float32, just the end is
cutoff, so reduced precision,
but exactly the same range.
So usually, bfloat16 is a
drop-in replacement for float32
in neural network workloads.
And also, we do the
multiplications--
16-bit multiplied by 16-bit,
which gives you a 32-bit
result, and we keep this
32-bit result. And finally,
the way it's architected
is that we have--
so try to remember from
your calculus courses
how to perform a
matrix multiplication.
Each result is a dot product
of one line of one matrix
and one column of
the second matrix.
And a dot product is
a series of multiply
and accumulate operations.
Multiply, plus, multiply,
plus, multiply, plus.
So that's why the unit
component of this array
is a multiply accumulator.
And by having 128 by 128
multiply accumulators connected
like this, I am not
expecting you to understand
this animation immediately.
You will have to spend a little
bit more time on it, I guess.
But the idea is that you load
one matrix into the array.
The other matrix, the values,
they flow through the arrays.
All the intermediate
sums, they flow
through the array
in this direction,
and what comes out from this
end are your final dot products
of the resulting matrix.
So it's a one pass operation.
No memory access while
you're doing this.
No writing to register
as an intermediate sum
and reading it back,
which is why it's fast.
And the second advantage is
that the unit of processing--
the 16-bit by 16-bit to
32-bit multiply accumulate--
it's a tiny piece of hardware.
It's not a full processor
that can do anything.
It's just a multiply
accumulator,
and that's why we can
cram a huge number of them
in each TPU.
Each TPU core, 128 by 128--
16,000 of those multiply
cumulative compute units,
and, of course, a TPU is dual
core, so 32,000 in total.
And this is the architecture--
so specifically for matrix
multiplications--
that gives TPUs an edge
in terms of density.
Density means power,
and power means cost.
A rough idea of the cost--
some people might have
seen my talk from last year
about building this model,
and I'm using this model
as a benchmark these days.
So this model trains in four
and a half hours on a GPU,
and if I provision
five GPUs in a cluster,
I can train it in one hour.
And I chose this example because
I can train it in one hour
also on a TPU v2.
So the rough idea is
this four-chip board
is roughly equivalent to
five of the biggest GPUs
that we have in terms of
speed, and in terms of cost,
is roughly three times cheaper.
So I could go on forever
and bore you to death
with all the technical
details, and if you
ask me questions I will,
but this is the dev zone,
so you want to see code.
So let's get code on the screen.
I love notebooks.
I will be using notebooks.
And by the way, have you
seen that in ML Engine
there is this new Notebook
Instances button where
you can provision a new instance
already set up for TensorFlow
or PyTorch with a GPU?
And also I set
one up with a TPU.
So what you get is a link
that's opens JupyterLab--
actually, I had it open already.
That's why it's doing this.
So let's go in my instance here.
And before we
start using TPUs, I
have to tell you a couple
of things about data--
how to load data--
because TPUs are very,
very fast accelerators,
and the first problem you're
going to encounter with TPUs
is not being able to feed
them data quick enough.
So let's talk about datas.
I will be working with a
data set on this model.
It's a detection data set
of wildlife photography.
So you see my classes
coming up in this notebook--
goldfish, shark, and so on.
But those are just the metadata.
What I want to show you
is how I load my images.
So here it is.
I will be using the
tf.data.Dataset API.
And that's an API that
is designed to prepare
data sets for training.
So it has all the
natural function
calls that you
need for repeating
across multiple epochs,
batching, shuffling, and so on.
How does it work?
So the first line
here is list files.
I give it a folder and I obtain
a data set of file names.
Then, the API allows me to map
any function on that data set.
Here I am mapping a decoding
function-- this function--
which has image.decode_jpeg
and read file before it.
So now from my data
set of file names,
I have a data set of images.
Then, I need to
resize and pad them,
so I map this function,
which does the resizing,
and then I repeat.
I can shuffle it.
I batch it into-- by 16.
And the API-- also,
this is interesting--
the prefetch call--
you can use this
to tell TensorFlow
to prefetch the next
batch while it is
training on the current batch.
So let's try to run this.
How do I iterate on a
data set in TensorFlow?
Well, now you can do
four images in data
set just the normal loop.
This only works in eager mode.
I'm in TensorFlow eager mode.
So you see I am
just displaying here
the shape of my tensor, batches
of 16 images of 384 by 384,
and it's painfully slow.
It's horrible.
I wait seconds for
16 images to come up.
Why is that?
Well, the reason is that I'm
reading for GCS, Google Cloud
Storage, which is a good thing.
From GCS, you can get
a crazy throughput.
But GCS is a storage
that is attached
through IP, the internet, and
it has a per file penalty.
This data set has
300,000 images.
You will not load
it image by image.
That does not work.
So what is the right
way of doing it?
The correct way is
to batch your images
into some file format that can
contain multiple pieces of data
at once--
some kind of record file format.
In TensorFlow, you usually
use the tfrecord file format,
but really, it has nothing
specific, special about it.
It's just a file format to cram
multiple pieces of information
in one file with tags.
So how does this work now?
Again, tf, the data
set list files,
I have a data set of file names.
This time I have done the
pre-processing on my files,
so I'm reading from a
different folder that
has these tfrecord files.
Then, I instantiate from that
tfrecord data set-- so now
I have a data set of records.
You have noticed
that I'm actually
doing it through this
interleave function
because this is how I can
read from 16 different files
at the same time.
And that's how you
get the throughput.
You batch your images
into big files--
100 megabyte tfrecord files--
and then read from 16 of them
at the same time, and then
map, repeat, and
everything else.
Let me show you that.
And, of course, the
decoding function
here is this function
where I simply unpack
what I put in my data set.
So what I put in my tfrecords
is the image, so metadata,
and since this was
a detection data,
the data set I have
the bounding boxes
and the classes of this data.
So yeah, it has displayed it.
It is a data set--
detection data set.
You can see ladybugs,
dolphins, and so on.
And this time-- well, look.
This time, my images are coming
out 16 by 16 at a steady clip.
So this is what you should
do when reading from--
well, when packaging
data for consumption
by training and
especially for TPUs.
So now, let's get training.
We have our data set.
Let's get training.
I'm switching here to a
different notebook technology
which you might know.
This is Colaboratory.
It's a free service on Google.
Very good notebooks
with a free back end.
And actually, if I click Runtime
here, Change runtime type,
I can get a TPU
accelerator for free.
I love it.
So this is a slightly different
data set, but not very
different.
Let me do this TPU detection.
It says, running on
TPU configuration.
Let me show what--
I'm here as well.
I'm loading from a
tfrecord data set,
but let me show you
what this data set is.
It's a data set of images.
So we will be
classifying flowers here.
And you recognize the
familiar data set API--
I hope by now it's
familiar-- with dataset.map,
dot repeat, dot batch,
dot prefetch, and so on.
So this is how I
create my data set.
I'm working in Keras,
so I hope most of you
recognize this
kind of Keras code
where you have a sequential
model and a bunch of layers.
The three lines of
code I would like
to attract your attention
to are these three.
This is how you train
a Keras model on TPU.
One line to find a TPU.
The second line to define a
TPU distribution strategy using
that TPU, and a third line to
transform your model into a TPU
model.
From there on, you train it as
you normally would in Keras.
So let me launch
the training here.
You see I'm doing tpumodel.fit,
passing the data set,
and what is going
on is interesting.
You see compiling.
Actually, what is going on?
My code is running
on a VM, a normal VM.
The TPU is attached
through the network to it.
TensorFlow defines my model
as a computation graph,
and it's that computation
graph that is shipped off
to the remote TPU for training.
And from that
computation graph, we
use XLA, the accelerated
linear algebra compiler,
to compile that graph
into TPU micro code.
So the TPU never sees
your Python code.
You have to bear that in mind.
It only sees your graph.
But if you use the
tf.data.Dataset API,
your data pipeline is also
packaged as part of this graph,
so the TPU will be
pulling data directly
from GCS, which
is very efficient.
And as you can see here--
this is what I love about TPUs--
on small to medium models,
I can get training times
of four seconds per epoch,
and I can iterate in minutes,
interactively, in a
notebook, on various models.
This is a smaller model.
This one has 3,000 images.
But you see, it's
already trained.
15 epochs.
We will see if it trained well.
Yep.
Here is the accuracy--
fine, it go to 75%.
And let us run a couple
of predictions from it,
see if it is classifying
my flowers correctly.
Running.
Displaying.
Here we go.
So it doesn't get
all of them right,
but the dandelion is fine--
the roses, the sunflowers,
dandelion.
And it mistook-- well,
this is a hard one, right?
You've got a couple of mistakes.
No model is perfect.
But this is what
I love about TPUs.
It's really fast, and you
can use them interactively.
But now, I want to show
you a bigger model.
A bigger one.
And for this, of course,
a bigger model that you
will be training
in half an hour,
that is not something that
you would be comfortable
doing in your notebook--
I mean, doing
interactively on a machine.
You don't want to be paying
for an expensive machine
to type code.
That is only when you
do interactive work.
I want something that
allows me to take a notebook
and launch it as a
job on hardware that
will be provisioned
just for that job
and decommissioned when
the job is finished.
That is the Fairing API.
So that's a new thing.
Reminder-- the three lines to
get a Keras model on a TPU.
The couple of lines to
load a tfrecord data
set, using interleave
to read from 16
different files at once.
But the last thing
that I want to show you
is a new API called Fairing.
So let me show you the code.
I'm back into my previous
notebook with the detection
model, and now, the
Fairing API is just
this-- it has three lines.
First, set builder to say
something about my environment.
I have actually
built my dependencies
as a Docker container.
That's a couple of lines.
I just have a couple
of [INAUDIBLE]..
The second one, which says
where are you deploying?
I'm deploying to GCP,
which is ML Engine.
And this is the hardware
configuration I want.
I actually want a Cloud TPU v3
to be provisioned for this job
and destroyed after the job.
And finally, what
am I deploying?
I'm deploying a full notebook.
This is a notebook-friendly API.
I have the name of
my notebook, and I
have a couple of sidecar files,
which I listed behind it.
Now, when I launch this, it
will build all of those things
into another Docker container.
I don't have to
know about Docker.
It does it.
And launch a job on ML Engine,
which I think we will see here.
Let us go to Jobs on
ML Engine, and write.
I have two jobs running.
This is a new one has been
running for 18 seconds.
And I actually wanted to
train this big model here
with you on stage.
In 20 minutes, it
was a bit tough.
You will have to come
to my repeat session
tomorrow to see this model
actually built on stage.
So I started it, you
see, 37 minutes ago--
that's the second job--
just before I stepped on stage.
And let me see if
it has finished.
Well, it looks like--
yeah, it looks like
we have a model.
It's here.
Where did I-- I just lost it.
It's this one.
Let me open this file.
Downloads.
It's still downloading.
OK.
Come on, download.
The internet is slow here.
So it will be downloading
and then re-uploading.
The uploading is the bottleneck
here and of the training.
But the result is
actually a notebook.
That is what I was saying
about a notebook friendly API.
I like working in
notebooks, because I
can do data preparation and
visually eyeball my data set.
I can have my training cell.
Then I can play
with a train model
and visually eyeball that
is doing the right thing.
All that in a notebook.
That is what I use when
I do interactive work--
in a notebook.
But then when I launch
all that as a job,
I don't want to
lose all of that.
So here with this API--
still downloading?
And then it will be uploading.
Sorry.
I will cheat and
actually show you
results from a previous run,
because we are running out
of time.
But here, with this API, I
can have all that as a job,
and the result of
the job, of course,
is the saved model in
the bucket where I told
it to save my model, and so on.
But it's also a fully
rendered notebook
where I have all my
cells rendered and I
can eyeball anything--
all the graphs, all
the visualizations--
that I have put in there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]